[MUSIC]
Finance and Accounting for
the non-financial executive that he
provides a thorough foundation and
finance and accounting for
executives that are not
financial specialists.
>> It's essential to have
an understanding of finance and
accounting because it
is the way companies keeps goal.
[MUSIC]
There are many people who rise to
positions of great responsibility,
without feeling great confidence in
their understanding of the subjects
of finance and accounting.
>> At some point,
you just need a solid understanding
of the key concepts, frameworks and
fundamentals in accounting and
finance to make the best decisions.
>> Fan for gave me a better
understanding of the stories that I
hear our business telling to the
markets, but also how I hear our
executives talking about investment
priorities within the business.
>> How a company decides
on a dividend,
understand the relationship
between balance sheet, and
income statement, and cash flow.
>> It's learning a language and
that language allows you to better
analyze what the constraints are,
what the opportunities are, and
gives you better information to
make that business decision.
>> Getting to learn how to create
value across different industries
was pretty fascinating.
And then to hear from the actual
managers of those companies within
the room was very valuable.
>> Better understanding
can be critical
to better corporate strategy And
of course better corporate strategy
is essential to being a winner.
>> Immediately you feel an energy
about this place.
>> I think the international
mix combined with the industry mix
was really powerful.
>> With this knowledge,
I now have the tools.
>> On our field better equipped in
a both on a personal basis to make
better financial decisions in my
life, but also better financial
decisions in my business and for
my customers.
>> People are going to walk away
with more competence and
more confidence.
>> Executives will make a better
contribution to their organization
when they go back.
[MUSIC]